[Music]
[Applause]
stranger things season three friendship
goals sub will make you think of your
bestie grab your bestie and get ready
because season 3 of stranger things is
all about friendship today we are
highlighting the biggest friendship
goals in the new season the gang is
going to be navigating the scariest
territory ever adolescence and they'll
only be able to make it out alive if
they rely on each other watch until the
end to find out which characters have
the most amazing friendship of all time
Dustin and Steven Steve Harrington and
Dustin Henderson had the ultimate
bromance but according to Harper's
Bazaar the relationship that blossoms
between the two characters was
completely unplanned Dustin and Steve
began their buddy bond in season 2 while
they were working together to capture
dart and fight those scary demo borgund
dogs
Dustin kept Steve from spiraling outs
after his breakup with Nancy and in
return Steve gave Dustin dating advice a
ride to the snowball and of course some
pretty rad hair styling tips in the
season 3 trailer their friendship is
still going strong they have an adorable
scene together in front of the ice cream
shop Steve is dressed in a sailor
uniform and they demonstrate the coolest
secret handshake ever then his coworker
Robin asks Steve how many children he is
friends with the answer is quite a few
but she's only got one bestie and that's
Dustin their social media post showed
that these two have an equally tight
relationship off-camera - fans love the
bond between them one fan pointed out
that Dustin doesn't have a father figure
or older brother to look up to so he got
Steve instead the duffer brothers shared
that they were delighted with the
surprise connection they said they fell
in love with the idea of the pairing
because the characters were both dealing
with heartbreak in season 2 and they
aren't the only ones who are digging
this friendship 11 and max the Mary Sue
online magazine totally nailed it when
they pointed out that it seems like the
female characters of stranger things
were physically incapable of talking to
each other this show would definitely
not pass the Bechtel test in the
previous seasons if you're familiar with
the Bechtel test it's a set
guidelines regarding female characters
in TV and film with three simple
criteria one it has to have at least two
female characters in it two the two
females must talk to each other and
three the conversation must be about
something other than a male character
the Defra brothers must have heard the
disappointed comments from fans and fix
the tense relationship between Max and
eleven in season three if you remember
in season two eleven saw max flirting
with Mike and she purposely made her
fall off her skateboard but they are
definitely becoming good friends in
season three the trailer shows them
eating ice cream and listening to music
together we are loving the fact that 11
gets to hang out and do normal teenage
kids stuff she really needed to get out
of hoppers cabin and have a normal life
now it looks like that's finally going
to happen for her and she's got a new
bestie he couldn't be happier about this
duo Lucas and Max for those of you who
haven't seen all of season 2 yet now is
a good time to cover your ears
spoilers ahead you've been warned ok
from the kiss at the end of season 2 we
know that Lucas and Max are more than
friends but like every solid romantic
relationship they started out as friends
first there's a clip in the trailer of
the two of them holding hands so it's
safe to say that their relationship is
going strong in season 3 but the show
creators had something interesting to
say about the teenage romances in the
new season they said that in addition to
Mike and Elevens relationship sparks
will fly between Mad Max and Lucas as
well but they added that since they are
only 13 or 14 year old kids it's harder
to find what bromance really means at
that age they said it can never be a
simple and stable relationship but that
there is fun to that instability max and
Lucas were such good friends in the last
season we hope that even if they break
up in season 3 they are able to remain
good friends but what do you guys think
are Lucas and Max better as friends or
boyfriends and girlfriends let us know
in the comments Steve and Robin the
season 3 trailer also highlighted the
promise of new friendships in addition
to the old ones from what we can gather
Steve got a new job at the new shopping
mall working at an ice cream shop those
sailor uniforms are the most adorable
things we've ever seen
anyway in the trailer Steve and Dustin
are doing their supercool secret
handshake in front of a new character
and this character is actually Steve's
age from her nametag we can see that her
name is Robin and she is all about
keeping it real
she watches with the confused look on
her face as Steve has an immature
lightsaber fight with Dustin then at the
end of the trailer she asks a pretty
important question how many children are
you friends with she asks how many
children Steve is friends with she's got
a point Steve needs to invest in a few
relationships with people his own age as
well as the kids and Robin appears to be
the perfect candidate as Steve's new
friend maybe Robin can save Steve from
whoever or whatever injected him in the
neck and the latest trailer that was
super disturbing anywho here's to
Steve's newest friendship the whole gang
if you were lucky enough to have a group
of friends like the ones and stranger
things hold on to them tight in the
season 3 trailer we see Dustin returning
from camp his melancholy loneliness is
scored beautifully by Motley Crue's home
sweet home dejected Dustin is sad that
no one is there to greet him he comments
that at least his turtle is happy he's
home suddenly all of his toys come to
life and roll out of his bedroom
Dustin is clearly freaked out so he
grabs a can of hairspray and follows the
toys to the living room we see that the
gang is hiding ready to surprise him
with a welcome home party and that 11 is
the one making the toys move it was the
sweetest thing ever when they all jumped
out to surprise Dustin unfortunately for
Lucas Dustin totally panicked he let out
a massive scream and spray Lucas right
in the face with the hairspray though
that's gotta hurt but before that we got
to see that the bond between Dustin Max
Lucas will Mike and 11 is stronger than
ever
they've been through so much together
it's great to see them having some fun
too and after seeing season three's new
and terrifying monster the gangs going
to need to band together more than ever
before what's your favorite friendship
and stranger things
leave your top pick in the comments
thanks for watching the things if you're
excited to watch season 3 of stranger
things be sure to subscribe to our
channel and like this video see you next
time
[Music]